[Music]  by far it's been a long as I've had it  one-on-one and so yeah it did think she  was gonna grab me this morning not gonna  lie so yeah that hurt and yeah I mean I  really want another one I want everyone  wants an end to your own debate guard  bottom line you got it it's two more  one-on-ones this week I hope my name is  called I'm one of them  Garrett yes love is in the air Becca  I could feel the air go out of all the  other guys in the room when my name was  called yeah sucks when you don't hear  your name don't matter what scene  Garrett get this one-on-one is such a  slap in the face when she has to know  that this is killing him  she has to know she's obviously way into  him way into him I thought me and Becca  you know had something special but maybe  I'm just completely out of my mind  like maybe there's nothing there like I  don't know maybe I'm just like making it  all up  [Music]